this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where dad is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice i am dave ramsey
your host dr john deloney
ramsey personality best-selling author
is my co-host today
he's also the host of the dr john delony
show the john de leni show on podcast
which is uh
massively popular you should be sure and
check it out you will be uh
you will learn things uh you will laugh
you will cry and you will be entertained
so be sure and check it out open phones
here at triple eight eight two five
five two two five with dr john here we
can talk about your life
and your oh i don't know mental health
things that are going on relationship
things that are going on as well as
money
we're here to talk about you this is all
about you
again triple eight eight two five five
two two five
jenny starts off this hour in charlotte
north carolina hi jenny how are you
hi gentlemen i'm honored to speak with
you both thanks so much for taking my
call
our pleasure how can we help well i want
to tell you dave your new website is
fantastic
so good job whoever you hired it's
amazing
thank you for a great one our in-house
team did that and i will give them a
give them a high five from you thank you
great my question um i've been a
stay-at-home mom for almost five years
now my husband and i have a two-year-old
and a five-year-old almost five-year-old
and my husband is a controller down here
he makes about 170.
and he he i would call him a very very
loyal
person employee he has great integrity
he's just
amazing and he um his job as a
controller down here his
his company keeps acquiring other
companies
and when he took the job five years ago
they warned him hey the books are a mess
um you know you're gonna stumble into a
lot of problems and this is just what
keeps happening with this company
and as they keep acquiring more
companies they're buying companies that
have
the books that are a mess i'm not an
accountant so i don't know anything
about that
um however he just recently recently
received a 140
000 bonus it was two weeks ago and we
have been looking
at already moving to different states
he's been looking at other jobs and now
it's kind of he's in the
debacle of well i just received this
huge bonus am i gonna look
like you know not loyal just like a
you know a not great employee not a
great person if i take this bonus and
leave
or shall he wait it out a little bit
longer would just love
your opinion from both you gentlemen and
what you think
what a fabulous question yeah that's
great
so you've hired and fired more people
than i have i'm i'm thinking through
my thoughts on that what do you think
dave i really like your husband
um loyalty is um
a type of integrity a piece of integrity
that is
uh a vast wasteland land in our culture
it doesn't exist very real doesn't exist
so
um i i really appreciate him being what
i would call old school
in that regard and um uh
but i do not think that the uh i think
he's been paid
and bonused for work that he has done
not work that he's going to do and
so i don't think he's doing anything
morally wrong or even violating loyalty
um i'm trying to reverse the shoes for a
second and say gosh if i was his
leader and we just gave him a hundred
and forty thousand dollar bonus on
hundred seventy thousand dollar income
let's do a fun thought experience i
would appreciate not getting
noticed two weeks later uh that would
feel a little icky uh
if the roles were reversed right uh but
also i don't expect someone
uh to to stay here
when uh when it's their time to go
um you can you know we tell people all
the time you can not work here and go to
heaven
and so um you know it's you it's this is
not uh
it's not the only place to work it's a
great place to work but it's not the
only place to work and
so sometimes people's season their
they they run through their uh the
energy that they had for the cause
uh i'm not leaving but other people have
and so i've you know come to accept that
so i i
i would think some amount of a little
bit of time i mean he wasn't you weren't
going to give notice next week anyway
still haven't found a job you don't know
where you're going but if you leave in
the next six months
i don't think you've done anything wrong
six minutes you didn't do anything wrong
but it just feels icky you know what i'm
saying
it's not cool yeah huh yeah
john what are you thinking yeah i'm
really wrestling with this one dave
because i'm trying to think if i gave
someone 140 000
like this is me being transparent i
think in some way i would be attempting
to
pay them for work done and by their
continued loyalty
and i think that's a bad motivator yeah
i mean um we've you know and the same
thing you'd just be saying
if i pay somebody a huge income right
but i don't want someone
especially someone i'm paying a huge
income to right to be here and not be
happy yeah be miserable their
time is done um you know it's bad enough
if you're paying somebody
a little bit of income in there that way
but it's really bad if you're paying
them a lot of money and their heart has
left
so we always tell people you know when
your heart leaves the building take your
butt with it
yeah hey jenny so is is he just tired of
the constant acquisitions is he is he is
it a toxic work culture where people are
not cool to him and then they just will
throw money at him
no it's nothing like that the the people
the people that um he works for oh the
bosses are my age they're 35 years old
and they just
built up this amazing company and
they're they're amazing people there's
no toxicity at all it's just
every company they acquire they're
getting it on a deal and so
here you go cpa controller just work
with these messed up
accounting books but i don't know like i
said i don't know anything about
accounting and it just keeps piling and
piling but
you know here's a security and
yeah here's a suggestion you know number
one
uh what controllers are supposed to do
is control that's why we call them that
and so they're supposed to clean up
messed up books that's that's what he's
that's that's what he's
if he goes to another company uh i mean
there are very few companies that do a
wonderful job with accounting most of
them do an okay job
or a really bad job uh and depending on
the size of the company the
sophistication of the company and so
forth but
um you know we have a stellar accounting
issue but but i think i think he might
ask for some help
i think he might be overwhelmed yeah
that's that's that's my thought
two little other pieces they've hired a
couple people to work under them
to work under him but then he ends up
training all the people which is great
though because he trains them
the way that you know uh he likes
they're gonna work
with him training them yeah right so he
loves that but then also he's not in
charge of any decision
too so i think and five he said five
years i'm putting in the work and
we can wait longer it was just kind of a
bummer because i mean
you know what i think i think what is he
looking for in the new job
there you go that's different and i
would go in and ask for that here
because i think he's got a pretty good
gig yeah
because and i'm basing that the big
thing you said is these are good guys
oh they're awesome yeah and if you go in
and go listen
i'm frustrated by this and this
and in order for me to feel lo think
longer term about this whole thing i
need to
i need some help with you adjusting
those things
yeah i need some control i need to make
some decisions here i need to be able to
do this and
i need to be able to implement this and
you're you know you're giving me all the
work but not the authority to get it
done
you're delegating the responsibility but
not the authority that's a breakdown in
basic leadership skills
whatever it is but i think you could
probably come at these guys and
reset your job and it might be the best
job you find because it sounds like they
love you and
you don't dislike them right very cool
conversation
i used to get 140 000 bonus i'm just
saying dave
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you'd like to join him
on the dr john delony show
you can do so by emailing ask
john ramsey solutions.com ask john
ramseysolutions.com or leave a voicemail
at 844-693-3291
is in 844-693-3291 connecticut hi tim
welcome to the ramsey show
hey how you doing better than i deserve
how can i help
good i first want to say thank you i
came across uh
videos and things in mind have been
extremely helpful and very informative
so thank you for all that that you do
thank you um question i'm calling about
so i'm a physician
um authorities married two kids uh my
wife and i between both of us
uh from undergraduate and medical school
at about a little over a hundred
thousand
combined runs and uh right now currently
you saved up a nice
uh emergency fund savings you actually
have enough to pay off
all of that
are you there sounds like we just lost
him
oh oh wait a minute and maybe now
are you there tim oh let me pick back up
all right i'll try again
i think they're messing with you in the
booth there brother all right hey tim
are you there
yeah yeah can you hear me yeah that was
all kelly's fault we'll just blame her
but um anyway the uh uh sorry about that
so you have a hundred thousand dollars
in student loan debt and you have a
hundred thousand dollars in the bank
correct give or take them you know i'm a
physician in practice in the 30s married
with two kids
what's your household income uh we're
making
program with bonuses and everything just
short of about 400. good for you
and we've got um we've got about 107 in
loans between
us i've got 15 savings and about 130 and
checking that it's sort of an earmark to
pay off the loans and obviously things
along those lines
um you know the cars are paid off for a
few years very reasonable
so your question is what tim uh question
specifically is
with all the pending legislation and
discussion about
loan forgiveness out there and where my
wife and i are kind of dividing this to
get a second opinion
essentially just to pay this all off
when we write this out keep making
payments and see what's potentially
going to come over the next
year or several years with regard to
loan forgiveness
well um looking at that through three or
four different lenses
i would write a check today and pay off
your student loans but let me give you
the lenses that i'm looking at it
through
and tell you how i came to that
conclusion um
number one uh
you borrowed the money you owe the money
waiting on me to pay off your student
loans as a taxpayer pisses me off
number two um
[Music]
the if they do pass this legislation
there
well there's nothing legislation there's
been a lot of discussion
i have never seen anyone
except uh the very far edge
fringe of the left suggesting any more
than fifty thousand dollars worth of
forgiveness
and a lot of the forgiveness proposals
that have been floated
uh are limited for high income earners
so on a practical basis if it did come
through it's probably not going to pay
off all of your loans and if it did come
through
um you're you are a real candidate for
it being limited it seems to be aimed at
there's a discussion of up to fifty
thousand there's a discussion of ten
thousand
uh and and a lot of the discussions were
income
limited meaning that if you were making
the kind of money you're making you
wouldn't qualify
because you're an evil rich person and
you must be punished in socialism
so um the um
[Music]
the third thing is just as a matter of
philosophical
uh even theologically the way i live my
life i just have never met
anyone who uh had a wonderful life
waiting on the government to fix it
right and so i just i just resist the
whole idea of
those idiots are coming to the rescue
because i'm old and i've never seen them
do it
right all they've ever done is take all
they've ever done is take from me
they've never given me anything
now they talk a lot and there's a lot of
you know
if if words were now if words were if
you could monetize their words we'd had
some money but
but they just talk and so real people do
what you do you went and got a medical
degree you have a wonderful medical
practice just go be prosperous and
don't wait on them to be your
your supply so to speak john you've got
a degree in
higher ed uh what are you thinking in
this it goes it to me it's less about
the government it's a it goes back to
your original point
it's a personal integrity thing for me
which is right
i i signed my name on a piece of paper i
looked some in the eye and said hey if
you'll help me get through school i
promise i'll pay you back
and man you're making four hundred
thousand dollars i'd write this check
today and
high-five my family and take my family
out for a debt-free dinner tomorrow
night
right well combined between my wife but
i understand your point that's what
we've kind of been
wrestling with is that we're obviously
you know doing well we've been able to
save and lived very
uh you know moderately to you know save
what we've done right well and you're
gonna you know you're gonna be worth
you're gonna have an incredible net
worth and uh and i don't um
want you to have anything but that um
you know i
i really don't um people are like well
medical doctors make too much uh
listen i don't want people that aren't
good at their medical practice working
on me they keep you alive
you know i don't want them practicing on
me you know so practice on somebody else
but yeah i mean i i like my doctor being
expensive
[Laughter]
it's preferable to me i uh i'm really
happy when the dentist
drives a really nice car that
probability he's not gonna hurt me and
i'm pretty much a [ __ ]
so um you know i like that i want to
have
i want to do business with successful
people
when they're successful is showing up in
their wallet so i'm proud for you tim
that you're making all this money
i i just it's a mindset for me that's
just making its way from
folks who are making 30 grand a year
that have 100 000
student loan debt all the way up to
making more than a quarter of a million
dollars
thinking oh man it's become a game now
how do i how do i
not pay it back right and i just man pay
you got the money in your account pay
the thing back it's the right thing to
do
yep mike's with us in spokane washington
hey mike welcome to the ramsey show
thanks dave thanks dr john i appreciate
you guys taking my call today
sure how can we help so um
i'm kind of doing long-term planning um
one i actually called you a year ago
because i felt bad about getting an
inheritance
um with you and ao and um on july
uh 21st me my wife had paid off
um with a little bit of help of the
inheritance 57 000
of debt um and then we have a fully
funded um
uh emergency fund um all right before i
got out of the navy during this kobe
pandemic so
that was a roller coaster um way to go
question i had and thanks for your
service i appreciate it
um so i'm doing reserves and right now
um with a lot of diligence and uber
and everything else or cash on my wife's
schooling
she'll be done with dental hygiene in
about
two and almost three years i'm not
worried about paying for it because
we're going to cashflow herself at
community college and then
she's going to use two years of my gi
bill
for the last few years out of public
school um
so that's all covered but this is the
weird situation
um my parents do not have the greatest
health they're 51-61 and i have an
autistic brother who i love to death
he's a year older than me he lives with
my parents
um luckily i have been blessed with a
wife who is completely open and adamant
about my brother living with us one day
and my parents smoke um they don't have
the greatest lifestyles
the thing that kind of terrifies me is
they're not the greatest with money
um i've talked to them numerous times
that their plan for if something ever
happens to them is
everything will just work out um
obviously that doesn't work and so i've
got a wife and two kids
and we don't have a house yet um the
plan was for us to buy a house when she
did summer schooling
um because then right
um because my brother is going to be
living with us
should we um look for our first house a
house that can accommodate
my family and my brother no not until he
comes to live with you
when it actually happens then you worry
about it but this could be
five years it could be 15 years
you do not buy a house based on your
worries or what might happen
or what might happen someday soon but
but when it happens
you may want to move and you may have a
little bit of an uncomfortable period
until you do move
with too many people on a smaller house
but no you buy a house for where you are
today
because we don't know what tomorrow is
going to bring
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five folks let's get real
for a minute some of you are getting
close to baby step
four you're almost out of debt almost
have your emergency fund in place and
you're freaking out
because you know you need to start that
baby step four saving 15 percent of your
household income for retirement you have
no idea how to start
that's okay it's okay to have questions
it's okay to not know how
most people have to learn things and the
trick is to work with an investing
professional
to teach you not to do it for you
blindly but to teach you we call them a
smart vester pro
and they can answer all those questions
in plain english
they don't sound like charlie brown's
teacher
when it comes to investing you need to
know what you are investing in
and when you sit down and work with a
smart vester pro who knows what the flip
they're doing
they'll make investing easy to
understand
we call that the heart of a teacher
do something about it text invest
to 33 789 if you're ready to start
investing
you need someone in your corner that
will guide you not do it for you
don't put money in something you don't
understand but learn
and get a smartvestor pro text invest
two three three
seven eight nine katie's with us in
springfield illinois hi katie welcome to
the ramsey show
hi dave and dr deloney hey what's up dr
john
hey thanks for taking my call my
question
has to do with um something else in a
house
my husband and i are both retired
our net worth is about nine hundred and
sixty-five thousand dollars
okay our pre-tax income from pensions
and social security is a hundred and ten
thousand dollars
annually excellent what do you do
anything on your current home
no it's been paid for what's it worth
for several years
um in talking to a realtor it's around
um probably 160 to 170
000 so you have 800 000 other than your
house
yes phenomenal so how much are you
wanting to move up in house
maybe 300 maybe to a total of 300 000.
you would like to build a house we have
never done that before and if
there's something that uh be a dream of
ours to do that are you gonna sell the
one that you're in
yes we will okay so then you would have
you would have a 300 000 house and you
would have a 1 million
net worth still only 300 of it would be
in a house instead of 165. what's wrong
with that
well nothing other than just a big step
you've been debt-free
you're going to be debt-free now because
you're going to pay cash for this
yes we are we are going to pay cash for
the house between
monies that we have saved in savings and
the
proceeds from the sale of our home
and we our current house has stairs and
we want to be on a ground level
what was your career and what was your
husband's career
my husband was a police officer
and then he went back to school as a as
a surgical nurse
and i am an educate with an education
and you're millionaires i'm so impressed
with you
thank you so john that's your mom and
dad yeah police officer and a teacher
it's incredible yeah it's really cool so
katie i i'm hearing this cool story
what's
what's the question there are you just
nervous to pull the trigger on it
we're nervous to pull the trigger
exactly all right there's no way
a teacher and a police officer and a
surgical nurse
are going to be scared about this little
thing
[Laughter]
we've always been so conservative and
saved and
um how old are you katie you know
besides the fact that you're 22.
65. okay here's the thing
there's two parts of this equation
probably
number one you have
earned it you are millionaires
you started from nothing and as a
teacher a surgical nurse a policeman
you became millionaires i am so proud of
you and a 300
000 house is not out of range you've
earned it you are not being opulent you
are not being silly
you are not being crazy and overspending
like some nutty
person on the television or something
like that you have earned it and this is
a very
reasonable percentage number two it is
not going to damage your finances one
penny
thank you you know what i think we just
needed to hear that
yeah uh i really appreciate it but
you know there's two sometimes we feel a
little bit of shame from having
succeeded
and sometimes there's some people in our
culture that want to help you feel a
little bit of shame for having succeeded
and i want to just tell you touchdown
spike the freaking ball oh
that's wonderful it's nice to hear that
from you and
we have worked really hard do your
touchdown dance i'm gonna see what it
looks like
you probably don't that you've worked
really hard you've saved really hard
and you get i mean if you're gonna pay
cash for a house
i already got a paid for a house that's
what i'm saying and they're just moving
up in cash
and let's not forget they're going from
stairs to
to a a like oh i guess more of a ranch
style house it's gonna be a safer house
for them over the long haul this is
i like that it's a great investment good
it's just everything there's nothing
wrong in this picture everything screams
wisdom
everything screams you earned it i'm
sorry waited and waited and waited so
you are true everyday millionaires hold
on i'm gonna
have kelly send you a copy of the book
everyday millionaires you need to read
it because you are one of them
well done chris is with us in austin
texas hi chris how are you
i'm well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
thank you for taking my call i'm a
little nervous but i'll get right to it
um
so basically i'm uh i'm
an addict in recovery i'm trying to get
my life together
i moved out here to austin a few years
ago i've got almost four years clean
time
and i found your book about a month ago
and it was just like seemed like the
obvious next step
to personal and financial recovery
i got really excited about it so i
realized all the money i had saved up
uh in my savings account was not mine
because i was about thirty thousand
dollars in debt so i took the twenty
thousand dollars i had
and i just threw it all with the debt
and now i've got about 9 000 land
um and uh
and now i'm trying to figure out like
how to move forward from here like i
i've got to every dollar app just like
you know i i i sit down and i look at it
and i'm like i don't know what to do
like i don't know how to like
assign every dollar um and i was
wondering if you had any advice on like
how
the first steps to to
get started there good for you yeah
first chris i want to celebrate four
years man that's a long
hard road and if you remember back to
step one or two of your original 12-step
program
you remember looking up and thinking man
i'm never gonna make stage six ever
i'm never gonna get out of stage six but
i'm nev same boat brother
and you're gonna take this one step at a
time you're gonna have a thousand dollar
emergency fund you have done the right
thing
and you're gonna slowly start walking
these baby steps right and you're gonna
work like crazy and pay the rest of your
debts off
rice and beans you're not gonna go out
you're not gonna hang out you're already
a hard worker you know what that's like
and then you're gonna save an emergency
fund you're gonna have a night sleep
that you haven't had in
years what what were you addicted to
uh i was addicted to uh anything i could
get my hands on
more i like to say but uh i like the
thing that really took me out
the thing that took me out was
methamphetamine yeah oh my lord
you drive that four years you're a stud
man that's exactly right that's
incredible that's a hard one
yep i'm proud of you so what do you do
for a living yeah
ups delivery driver what is good what a
stud oh man that's
awesome what a great position yeah all
right so here's what we're gonna do
i'm gonna put you into ramsey plus i'm
gonna pay for it
because i want to be part of your
recovery story the second chapter of
your recovery story
all right and we're going to teach you
every little thing and make sure you
learn how to do
every dollar the app make sure you have
a coach in your corner
make sure you go through financial peace
university it's all in there
i'm going to pay for all of it and then
you call us back when you're debt free
and tell us how
good life is hold on kelly's going to
pick up we'll get you signed up for
everything young man
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
best-selling author and host of the dr
john deloney show which ought to check
out as a podcast
uh it is uh if you're not listening to
it you're one of the few
it's really a going zoom zoom steve is
with us in daytona beach hey steve how
are you
hey dave how are you guys doing today
better than i deserve brother what's up
that sounds great my wife and i are in a
dilemma
um we want to pay our house off we go
127 000 on a 250
000 uh duplex and she was wanting to
know if she should go back to work
or if we should use our retirement to
pay it off
now here's the numbers we're both debt
free
uh we have a fully funded emergency fund
and our
retirement amount is 400 excuse me 464
000.
what do you think total 464 thousand
all that's all the nest egg you guys
have correct
well plus we have i have a fully i have
a pension a lifetime pension and we have
the social security
okay and so what is your income nowadays
in return 48 000 okay 48 000 you're able
to live on that
oh easily okay plus if you didn't have a
house
if you didn't have a house plan it'd be
real easy to live on oh yeah you know
that
yeah so the money's all in 401ks or iras
and that kind of stuff
the money is in mutual funds and roth
iras
okay how much in mutual funds that's not
in retirement
um well actually it's all in retirement
okay okay so it's all in
it's all in an ira or a 401k but in a
mutual fund or not
okay correct there were four four or
three because i was a school teacher but
okay so you got
467 000 if we take out 150 to pay off
taxes and
the house right um then you've got 300
000.
we have three yeah 3 000 200 000 plus
you'd have 300 000 left over right
correct after you paid off the house and
the taxes
and you can live on your income without
touching the 300 000
oh easily these are and you're 65
correct okay my wife's 55 and so if you
don't
go back to work she does not need to go
back to work if you don't touch
this money the 300 if it's invested
at at a rate of return of 10 percent it
will double in about seven years
so at 72 you'll have 600.
at 79 at 79 you'll have 1.2 million
wow that's if you don't touch it
right in six years she'll get social
security too so well that's the but i
mean you're living on the 48 you'll live
on the 48 plus
uh her income will go down but then
it'll go back up with social right or
she she's
oh no she's not working now no she's
we're both retired
okay that's right she was thinking to go
back to work now oh pass the house
no not as long as you don't have to
touch this nest egg
i mean after you pay off the house as
long as you're not living out of the
nest egg i'd pay off the house
today and uh i don't think just to go
back to work because of the numbers i
just gave you
sounds pretty comfortable to me so walk
me through that normally we would tell
folks
don't cash out retirement but he's got
this pension
it's don't cash out retirement before
you're retired
uh okay but they're retired so they've
got they've got taxes but no penalties
okay if it's his retirement and we can't
carry shares out she's only 55 but
i'm assuming he's got enough that they
can do this but
between the two of them they'll have a
nest egg of 300 left over after we cash
out his
a portion of his to pay off the house
and then how do you get
what's the difference between a
non-retirement mutual fund and a
just a regular old john went to the
store and got a mutual fund
well the mutual fund john went to the
store doesn't have
uh didn't have any tax protections okay
and so the taxes have already been paid
on it so it's it's after i get my
paycheck
i'm contributing to now so if i take if
i take 100 and
if i need 127 000 out of a mutual fund
that's not in a retirement account
i take 127 out because i've already paid
taxes through my
payroll right but if it's over in a 401k
i got to pay taxes on it so i got to
take enough out to pay the taxes and the
127.
okay so now we got a 150 160 000
withdrawal out of 467. okay
so i don't want to be taxed i would have
cashed out if he had mutual funds
that were not in retirement i would have
used those first because the taxes would
have been paid on them they're
going to take out extra money i want to
leave as much money in their churning to
make more money as i can
okay so i would i would have not i would
have gone to that first
okay to uh to let it well just tax
efficiency is what it amounts to
brian is in rochester new york hey brian
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call i
appreciate it sure how can we help
um got myself into a little situation
here so
i got myself into a car lease uh
sometime back in november
of last year i was working from home at
the time so i wasn't going to put a
whole lot of miles on it
um just recently got myself into a new
position
as of a couple months ago uh which is
now more of an outside
sales position which requires a lot more
travel
so um basically i
have the leased vehicle i'm putting a
lot more miles on it now than i
had originally anticipated and i'm just
curious as to what your thoughts were as
far as what i should do
at this point um well you
you really got in a stupid mess and then
you made it even worse with adding the
miles to it so
it was never smart and it never it
didn't just get dumb all of a sudden
because of the miles it was dumb to
start with
so we're gonna get out of it that's what
we're gonna do uh have you looked up
what the car's worth
uh i have a general idea as to what it's
worth
so it originally was about a forty
thousand dollar vehicle
uh it's probably now worth somewhere
around
thirty four okay look it up on kelly
bluebook kbb.com
on private sale we'll use 34 for our
discussion have you called the
fleece company and asked what the early
buyout is on the fleece
no i have not okay it was originally 40.
i assume you put down nothing let's call
it 37
is the buyout meaning the early payoff
where you pay off the whole freaking car
because you sell it
okay if that's the case you're three
thousand dollars in the hole 37 minus 34
if those numbers turn out to be true
they're probably not going to be too far
off of that but you need to get the real
numbers and then um
so yeah you just you gotta have that
three thousand dollars and then we've
got to have enough to get you a uh
uh some kind of car to drive around but
if you're putting a bunch of miles on it
whatever you're driving you're
destroying its value
so you need the least expensive car that
will get the job done which means it
doesn't break down
and uh and it's not some kind of dinky
butt little smart car because you spend
all day in the car and you're going to
be
at the chiropractor's office if you have
that so you need to you need a like a
real
car not a pretend car and uh
and you know something that that is
going to be reliable but you know maybe
a 10 000
car max and even if you borrow the 10
000 it's better than being 34
000 in debt and running the smiles up on
this lease because you're gonna get
hammered
with the miles you're putting on it at
the end it's really turned into a bad
situation
don't lease cars period
so folks let's talk about that for a
second okay
78 of the bmws that leave the lot this
year will be leased
really caught new car dealers
make more money in their pocket
on the transaction when you finance or
lease a car
then they do by far uh
they make about six times more if you
lease or finance the car
with them than they do if you just walk
up and pay cash for the car
there's not a lot of spread on cars they
don't make a ton of money
the most profitable square footage on
the new car lot is
the finance office the second most
profitable square footage is the shop
it is not the showroom floor the
showroom floor is the gateway drug
it's what gets you hooked and so the
average car
dealer will make 1500 to 2500 dollars
in their pocket cash on a
25 000 car on the lease
they make five to seven hundred dollars
less
if it's bank paper or chrysler motor and
it's just straight up
debt and they make two thousand five
hundred dollars
less if you pay cash on a twenty five
hundred dollar on twenty five thousand
dollar car
the reason all people are leasing cars
is because they're selling you that
because they make more money on that
than they do anything else
so please don't let them set the tone
for your finances
and when you drive down the road and see
all these bmws just know it's not real
yeah it's a morale it's a rental car
it's a rental
car
and it's not just beemers it's lexus
it's everything
yeah you're getting slayed people
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us dr john dolone ramsey personality is
my
co-host today as we take your questions
about your life
and your money dr deloney does the dr
john deloney show which is a ever
popular podcast about
mental health issues of all kinds
relationship issues boundary issues
depression anything like that anything
you want to fall into in that category
you can jump in today he's here to help
you here
as well as at that show if you want to
be a part of
that show all you have to do is also you
can email him
at ask john ramseysolutions.com
john ramsey solutions dot com the phone
number here triple eight eight two five
five two two five also
in the next week or two we're gonna be
doing an entree leadership
theme hour which means we're going to be
taking calls from those of you about
business about
leadership starting a business running a
business any business questions
our entree leadership team and i i love
working with small business folks
and helping them uh get things moving at
a different level
at a faster speed than they ever have
before and uh if you have an entree
leadership
question and you want to be part of that
hour just email me
at dave on air at ramseysolutions.com
on air at ramseysolutions.com kelly i'll
get in touch with you
and make you a part of that upcoming
show
jeff starts off this hour in youngstown
ohio hi
jeff how are you i'm doing well how are
you better than i deserve how can i help
yes we our families um all
fall upon like difficult medical
problems and my mother-in-law passed
away two years ago
and we tried moving my father-in-law in
with us but he's developed dementia and
can't stay with us
and we aren't sure like how to set up
trust for his grandchildren to protect
his assets
um so medicare and medicaid can
help assist pay for his stay at the
nursing home
or if that's even ethical uh it's not
only
unethical it's illegal illegal yeah so
it's
it's called welfare fraud um and so um
when you sign up for government
assistance based on being poor
and you're not poor because you hid the
assets yeah that's
unethical and the federal government has
the ability to look back five years and
undo
any trusts or anything you've done to
move assets out of his name to quote
protect
him from medicare so here's the thing if
he goes to a restaurant
and buys dinner he expects to pay for it
and when he goes to the nursing home he
should expect to pay for it
okay that's sorry i wasn't sure because
like he worked his whole life and then
he just in a matter of years everything
will be gone
yeah yeah three years everything you've
worked for his entire life's gone and
there's nothing
yeah but nobody did anything to him
nobody nobody stole from him or anything
like that he's spending
his life savings on his care
that gets stella's house to pay for his
care for his care
well he doesn't need his house anymore
he's spending his money on his
care to take care of him now
here's uh how much how much in assets do
you think he has
um after he sold his home and sold his
vehicle a soul of everything
about 250 000. okay and how old is he
74. and how bad is the dementia
uh it goes in waves it'll go two or
three weeks till be really good and then
there'll be
weeks where it's really bad there's
there'll be
people chasing him and so on how long
has he been struggling with this
about a year to a half a year since his
wife passed two years ago to really
progress it
rapidly yeah okay i'm so sorry you guys
are facing this it's a hard thing to go
through
okay yeah but um thank you yeah
so you guys go shopping for a nursing
home
and let's let's just let's look at some
numbers for a second i'll actually pull
out i've got some statistics here on my
desk
on this uh on average okay
so okay the average
nursing home stay is
um let me see here see
[Music]
where to go where to go 70 of claims are
for
uh in-home care 12 or for assisted
living 15
for nursing home now uh two things i
want you to check on
one is i want you to start pricing out
some in-home care
has he already sold the house yes oh
it's already gone okay so he's going
into a nursing home
okay cool yeah he's our he's already in
one but we're trying to
see how to tell you what we can do best
for him and protect his athletes first
grandchildren
with what you've told me i am going to
project
that he's going to have about an average
stay
yes the average stay nationally is 2.4
years
okay it's heartbreaking it's
heartbreaking to turn
your your loving relative into a
statistic
okay but if he's if he stays there
three years and spends 40 000
a year he's only used up half of his
assets
his is 8 500 a month so his is going to
be
that's ridiculous that's really
expensive
it is you need to get a different
nursing home
okay look into other ones yeah that's
that's
double yeah well that's what i was his
ass that's
so he stays three years everything's
gone yeah yeah
240 000 yeah the average nursing home
stay in america is 50 000.
that's the average okay means it's a lot
i mean some are cheaper
yeah and yours is double and i had a
um relative who was put on hospice
and live three years and so yeah it's a
very real possibility
in three years he's doing just he's not
doing well but he's still alive
and um yeah y'all are out of money
that's way too expensive man
yeah okay and and so the problem is
it's so harmful when you're watching
someone that you love
that uh you know with especially when
you're talking about dementia
and so forth it's just it's
heartbreaking and then you reduce the
conversation to a math formula and
that's just really
tough but the truth is it helps me
if i'm in that situation to reduce it to
a math formula
because i don't have the panic of
running out of money
right and so i'm really glad you called
uh and
because the main thing you've discovered
is he's probably not going to run out of
money
but you need to move him okay and you've
got to do a
psychological 180 here brother this
money
is not quote unquote your grandkids or
your children's assets
this is the money that is going to get
him through the last stages of his life
and i'm super grateful that he was in a
position
to be able to help pay for that the
nursing home is not stealing
they're serving correct and it stinks
you guys did you did sign up for the
you know the freaking ritz carl i mean
the freaking rich carlton but you're not
um but but they're not stealing from you
they're they're just serving they're not
that's
his money let's take care of him it's um
otherwise y'all would have asked him for
it
that's the mind shift yeah that's the
mindset shift you're talking about that
is necessary
and so folks um yeah you don't you don't
quit your job so you can get
unemployment
and you don't hide your assets so you
can get welfare nursing home and you
don't spend your parents money before
they're done using it
right because then you gotta walk it
back and it feels like a loss yeah
right that's a good idea too this is the
ramsay show
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash
budget we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
so
[Music]
so taxes
well these days there's pretty much two
ways to do your taxes you either do them
online by yourself
or you pay a pro and we're thrilled to
offer ramsey smart
tax as a way to do them online this year
very inexpensively very quickly very
easily
if your taxes are simple that's the way
to do it simple software
ramsey smart tax uh we can handle all
the deductions a standard one
or if you've got enough to make it worth
your while itemized deductions
uh you can do that in ramsey smart tax
and if things get a little tricky you
can do an extension you can do that with
the software
if you want to refund let me remind you
refunds are just a sign that you
overpaid
all year long and you got some of your
money back
santa claus does not live in dc
uh if you did overpay you should get the
refund but
make sure you change your w2s going
forward w4 is going forward so that you
don't get refunds anymore because that
means you've just loaned the government
money interest free all year long it's
easy to get started text
tax to 33 789 use the promo code
easy to get the federal classic version
for only
ten dollars ramsey smart tax you can
file
online for ten dollars use the promo
code easy
text tax two three three seven
eight nine david is in san diego hi
david welcome to the ramsey show
thank you mr ramsey appreciate you
taking my call my pleasure how can i
help
well here's my situation i i'm retired
i own a piece of real estate that i live
in and i own a condo
that is a rental both are paid off
i'm thinking of leaving california for
another state
and i'm wondering whether i should rent
these properties out
or sell them and take a very substantial
capital gains hit uh
the one you live in uh is are you
married
yes you make an up to a half a million
dollars profit on it no taxes at all and
there's no capital
and then there's capital gains on the
rest of it so how much how much of a
gain have you got on their residence
well after you take the 500 000 out the
gain would probably be
about 1.5 okay
and then i've got a condo that's fully
depreciated
that's probably 1.2 okay
the condo you can do a 1031 tax deferred
on and buy rental property in the other
market
and roll that capital gain into that
property
your personal residence you can't yeah
i'm not sure i want to continue being a
landlord though oh okay
then why would you be a landlord in
california when you're out of state
just because just because you hate the
taxes don't want to pay the tax
yeah yeah i've been didn't cash it all
out gonna be almost
almost 700 000 yeah yeah
yeah i'm out of there though i would not
long distance landlord
and i certainly wouldn't long distance
landlord that residence that's a
ridiculous rental property
it's too high it's not a good rental
house it's too big
well it's in coronado and i could
probably rent it for five grand a month
which is horrible rate of return on that
much money
well yeah on two million dollars yeah
yeah that's a whole that's awful
you know but it's almost it's almost the
principle of the thing you just don't
want to give
that much money to the state of
california well it's the feds i mean
you're getting hammered on taxes yeah
if you don't want a landlord you're
going to write the check for all the
taxes if you will landlord on
a little bit of it you can roll the
condo into a 1031 where you're moving
i would not keep the properties no i
hate taxes
i hate taxes so bad i can't breathe i
hate taxes they take some
dadgum much of my money every time i sit
down to do this with
my guys at this time of year i just i
spend about a day mad
it's just ridiculous i hate them i'm
with you i get it but that's not going
to force me to make a bad decision for
my
life i'm just gonna go well
you know they're just screwing me again
thank you washington dc
you bunch of parasites you're a tick on
the butt of america
and you know i just have to just tip my
hat to them they got me again
and i'm out of here because you know
that's what i would do if i were if i
woke up in your shoes i'd be selling all
of it
and out of there if you're out of there
i'm not staying there
i'm not keeping rental property long
distance and i'm not going to keep a
property that really shouldn't be a
rental property with a horrible rate of
return i.e your house
um just because i'm pissed about taxes
just just write the check dude and move
on if it's time to go it's time to go
and um sounds like it's time to go
susan's with us in lexington hi susan
how are you
i'm well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so um our daughter got married
and things didn't work out and so
she was three hours away she got a job
only making about forty thousand we
wanted her and our daughter close
so that we could help out while she was
at work so we bought a house for her to
live in
close to us we told her
that the rent she would still have to
pay rent but the rent would be
manageable for her
well then she found a love interest and
she
despite our beliefs she had the love
interest
move into the house um and we told her
this is not part of the deal if he's
gonna live here because she is 28
this is against our beliefs we don't
agree with it
your rent is no longer subsidized so we
are raising your rent
to a thousand dollars a month
um well the house was bought in august
yes i could have gotten fair market
value so now
talking to the tax accountant and with
this man living there that's making
significantly more than her i'm going to
say a hundred thousand dollars
a year how do i
approach this with explaining to her
she's already knows
that it's against our beliefs and that
um we don't agree with this
but she can definitely afford more than
a thousand dollars a month
this is not it's not about the money
you're the landlord this is a values
issue you take her out to breakfast and
you say here's the deal this is what's
going to be you got 30 days and this is
what's going to happen
do i worry about the relationship of
our granddaughter when she turns around
and says you set the boundary
and your daughter ran up against that
boundary you can't hold
she crossed it you can't hold somebody
else
like you can't hold somebody else's
response to your boundaries
if she chooses to poison the well of
that relationship that's a choice she's
gonna make
but you're doing um what you feel is
best within your values
so here's the thing okay okay you
strongly believe and i do too
that what she's doing is wrong she knows
that you believe that and and the reason
you believe is wrong is you don't
believe it's good for her
it's not i don't think she's recovered
from her exact marriage
you don't think it's good for her it's a
good example for the child
amen and amen amen and amen don't
believe me and so
all of those reasons all of those
reasons have nothing to do with you
being selfish
these are all you loving her
right yes your concern is for her
it's not like you know like you you have
not been violated
other than that other than the fact that
she just thumbed her nose
at your upbringing at her upbringing but
you have not been violated uh you're
just trying to
say i don't believe in this because i
don't think it's good for people and
you're one of the people that i don't
think it's good for
and here's what happens and you cannot
you cannot have your
uh your values and what you believe
about something harming someone
held hostage by the chance to see your
grandkid
you're being blackmailed and i don't
even know if you're there yet i feel
like you're anticipating black male is
that fair
i'm i believe so i i believe um
that she could say well you know i can
move further away
sure yeah you can do yeah yeah you can
do a lot of things
here's where it hurts when you think
you've done everything
right you've tried to help you in fact
you have helped
it feels unnatural when someone turns
around and bites that hand
and it is unnatural it hurts it's wrong
and that doesn't still have to do
lovingly kindly with no mother voice
just to smile and just say honey i love
you
you know i don't go along with this and
so you guys have 30 days to move out
here's where we are
because we can't we can't endorse this
style of life
your values are your values or your
values period
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five anna's in new york city hi anna how
are you
hi i'm doing well thank you dave good um
so
my question is that i'm a public school
teacher in new york city
and we're offered something called a tda
a tax deferred annuity should i
contribute
um to this teacher retirement fund even
though it generates
only a six to seven percent simple
interest
yeah no okay simple interest is fine
that's standard compounding interest
but uh so you can do better than seven
percent and you can do better than a
teacher's annuity
if you have the option it's not
mandatory right
no no it's not mandatory yeah you need
to step outside of that
and do roth iras are you married
yes okay do a roth ira for you roth ira
for your husband
is your husband working and does he have
a 401k available
yes he does okay let's let's get our
baby step four
we call it 15 of your income going into
retirement
between those three things his 401k and
two roths
uh because you can get it into good
growth stock mutual funds and make
you know at least 50 percent more on it
than you would make there
absolutely yeah and it's just got a lot
more flexibility
the uh the problem with most
teacher retirement packages
are that it's uh government affiliated
obviously and what happened was the
insurance people got very involved
in the early days in the 403 b systems
403 bs you see them in non-profits in
hospitals and in
uh with teachers in government right and
so
uh and when the insurance people got
involved they put in annuities which
don't which
like you found don't don't have a good
rate of return and or
are stacked high in fees and so it's a
substandard
uh product compared to what your husband
has say over as a 401k at his work
i did not know that so that means if the
insurance is involved and it's only
getting a six percent rate not
necessarily
but i mean the insurance company an
annuity is an insurance product right
okay it's a savings account insurance uh
uh
company and it's just stacked high and
fees she's in a fixed annuity which is a
horrible product
and then you can also get into a
variable annuity
which has a series of growth stock
mutual funds in it so it starts to look
pretty similar then
if you can select however you're just
going to run into much higher fees
and so you can just i mean
99 times out of 195 times out of 100 if
i'm finding if i'm working with a
teacher
they're better off doing it somewhere
than at the school system there's just
very few of them are
high quality retirement plans like
you'll find in corporate america yeah
or like you can get on your own with a
roth ira with a smartvestor pro
that kind of thing suzanne's in syracuse
new york hi suzanne how are you
i'm very good thank you thanks for
taking my call sure what's up i recently
well i recently i've been i got
remarried about a year and a half ago
and so we sold my house and i live in we
live in his house
i cleared 132 thousand dollars on the
house and i wanted to know what i should
actually do with emily
okay remarriage so
uh you went through a divorce oh yeah
like
30 years ago oh a long time ago okay
good oh then like 22 years i was
divorced yeah okay all right
um and uh are you all combining your
finances
um no we keep our finances separate okay
my husband does not have good credit
okay all right and how old are you two
i'm 58 and he's 65. okay
all right um i think it's fine for you
to do
uh you don't have any debt i take it
i'm just the house okay his house
his house yes yeah so if you're not
going to combine your finances then this
money is invested in your name
for you in mutual funds i'm going to
challenge that over time it's a brand
new marriage i don't have to challenge
it today
you've lived your lives as as single
individuals for a long time so
emotionally
the collision of the emotion the
collision of your emotions to combine
your finances
just opens up a lot of stuff inside your
brain i'm sure
but i do want to tell you that very few
people succeed
financially when they don't combine
their finances
so but you don't have to do it today but
i want you i want you to
over time soften on this
and be willing to reach over and pay off
his house
our house because it needs to become our
house because it needs to stay in the
will
you keep it if he dies not his kids
yes and i already contribute i take part
of the mortgage every month
well it's just like having a roommate
see
and so there's a yes there's a spiritual
advantage a financial advantage a
relational advantage
to long-term beginning to you know for
this not to be his house it's our house
because you're in the will
and um and it's and there's a spiritual
advantage for you guys to be operating
together what's the hesitancy
um he has very bad credit people would
take the money creditors will come and
take the money
was he he got he's got judgments against
him
um yes how many i don't know but he has
terrible credit so we would never
credit doesn't people don't take money
because of bad credit they take money
because of lawsuits on defaulted debts
well then he has assaulted death how
many and you need to know
yeah how much i i don't know yeah yeah
you need to figure that number out
because it's
it's like he has cancer but i don't know
how bad it is yeah it's a looming shadow
of your relationship
and so what's going to happen or what is
happening is y'all are coming up with
alternative ways to go out to eat to use
dave's cancer analogy
but you don't even know what the problem
is or how bad it is right
and so what happens is you start taking
a
a little bit of a step here and a little
bit of step to the left and to the left
and all of a sudden you wake up and
you're a mile apart from each other
and you didn't mean to you didn't do it
on purpose you love each other
but you are not on separate same roads
and you don't even know what that what
the cancer is
yeah i'd pull a credit report so there's
two things
on the practical level i would get a
full list of everything
and you all start working a plan you
don't have to put your money towards it
today
but you need to start working a plan and
know what the flip's going on in his
life he's your husband
and uh it goes with the territory uh
you're not your roommate
and uh you cannot you can't it's not
this is not a healthy relationship the
way you're going into it's what john's
saying
now the second part of this is when you
say
he's got bad credit three times you've
said that
i also think i heard you saying i think
he's irresponsible
that's right he he's never been very
close money so he's never saved money he
has no retirement
do you think he's irresponsible
he pays his bills like he can't do you
think he's irresponsible
i think he was in the past yes okay if
he's responsible now
he's a guy that has a mess left over
from the time when he was
irresponsible and it's a good thing he's
got you and his life and the two of you
can work together to clean up his
mess from his former irresponsibility
but you if you can't trust him going
forward because he's irresponsible we've
got a whole nother barrel of fish hooks
here
right because it sounds like he's not
quite being honest about
what he owes or a situation and he's not
a shame about it
and it sounds like you're not being
honest about how much you
kind of have to hedge your bets against
him because he's not trustworthy
and that is a recipe for this thing to
end up in ash that's why i asked you how
long you've been divorced and because if
it had been five years
and the guy before was uh horrible with
money
and irresponsible it's easy to transfer
the former
uh the former husband ex-husband's crap
onto the new husband
and uh whether it be right or not and so
uh yeah i think you guys need to work on
you having a belief that he's going to
be a
good responsible wise man going forward
and then based on that we're going to
work through
cleaning up his mess together and uh
even
down to the end of the story being that
yeah your 132 000 eventually rolls up
into this and pays off that house
but you're the house is in your name i
mean the how you're in the will
and the house has your name on it as
well if you're going to pay it off
you're going to combine your lives and
your finances and we're going to work
together
in a way that is responsible and wise
y'all have got secrets in your home
and you can't you can't build a a new
marriage
on secrets you can't sustain an old
marriage on secrets
y'all got to sit down and have a
truth-telling session with each other
relatively soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at 825.5225
john and i were talking at the break
john i want to riff on that a little bit
um
there there's a com personal finance
we've said around here for many years i
figured it out a long time ago
i'm a finance nerd i've got all the
degrees and all the letters and licenses
to crap after my name that says i'm
supposed to know something about money
and i couldn't get people to do it
because if you just do the math the math
works right if you do the stuff that
causes the math to move the math moves
a hundred percent of the time but the
problem is not the math
problem is not the formula the problem
is not the process the problem is you're
injecting a human being
into that process and so we've often
said personal finance is 80
behavior it's 20 head knowledge
and with your arrival at ramsey we've
even started to realize
i kind of had it in the back of my head
but it's been brought to the forefront
in my mind
even more this whole concept i mean with
ken coleman's
success in the career space helping
people with their careers and how that's
tied to money and you helping them with
their mental health and relationships
and how that's tied to money and how
money's tied to mental health and
how money is tied to having a career and
the things are all interactive there's
this
spin-up of all of the different things
we talk about here at ramsey even
leadership from monterey leadership
rolls into that
discussion as well but but it's more
than just
personal finances 80 behavior
because then you have to say behaviors
are affected by
good and bad by relationships yeah
historical ones present day ones a lack
of them
a desire for more or deeper yeah it's
all wound up in there
disingenuous relationships broken
relationships toxic relationships
wounded relationships healthy
relationships
and it's like um we were talking the
other day uh
in entree leadership the uh uh
all the studies and and all the
interviews we've done on family
businesses and what we found is
that the family business is as
dysfunctional as the family
a hundred percent of the time if the
family is pretty functional
and does conflict well and has good
boundaries
then they can do business together but
families that are just crazier than hell
trying to run a business together they
just create a dadgum chaotic mess
because it's a chaotic mess already and
they just plug business into it
and money's kind of the same way yeah
when you're when your life is chaos
and there's addiction and boundary
problems
and your mother goes and buys a house
mother and dad go and buy a house for
you to move into
and and and they have are strong people
of faith
strong christians and they don't believe
in sleeping around people you're not
married to and you go move your
boyfriend
in and you think that that's just okay
and you don't think this has any effect
on money
as if money is somehow separate a
separate subject from your freaking life
they've got it so they they owe it to me
well just the whole thing is
this idea that i can i can keep the
money thing over here and i can control
it in a separate pocket
and i can go over here and b to the
right and be dysfunction
dysfunctional in any way and not affect
the money
i'll dave i'll never forget driving home
and i think it was a
it was a radio station and it was this
breaking news these researchers had
found
they had gone back to the i think it was
the was it the holly madison whatever
that website was
for adult cheaters oh yeah yeah right
and so they had scanned it all out for
all the fake stuff and then they had
gotten the ones that had credit cards
these were real accounts and then they
had gone looking for
businesses where these folks were
attached to them
and the shocking revelation of this the
sociological finding
was that there were more ethical
complaints in these businesses
where these leaders were cheaters
shooters
on their spouses and the the question
was
or the the revelation was we have
separated this in the business world
we don't care about anything but results
just show up and give us results and we
will
shield what's going on outside of this
building and they were saying
we don't know if we can do that anymore
because there's a correlation if you're
not a good person over here
chances are you're not going to be a
good person in here they're all worried
those of us with common sense go
duh i remember sitting in my car going
yeah you got it and you paid a lot of
money for this study
i could see that yeah but but it was
man that stuff where you are
relationships how you treat people and
money
dave and john how can i uh
how can i build wealth uh when my
husband and i aren't on the same board i
aren't on the same page and he's being
irresponsible with money and i'm being
responsible
you can't it says if you can keep the
question
in intimates that you can keep these
things separate right
and there's a holistic part of this that
your values
and how functional you're like you are
in your life
your ability to do conflict your ability
to set boundaries your about
ability to head into healthy
relationships
not needs-based relationships not uh
i'm so lonely i could cry so i'm gonna
go ahead and marry an abuser
right and then think the money's going
to work out right
it's it's all tied together so hard dave
to look in the mirror and be
take on a stock of ourselves and if we
can't do that which is hard
it's hard to invite people in and say i
need some honest reflection here
and that's what makes a great group of
friends that's what
makes a great pastor a therapist that's
what makes somebody good who will sit
there
and hold a mirror up to you and say this
is what i'm seeing yeah
and you can say i'm not okay man i don't
know how to handle money i'm not good in
relationships this whole thing is just a
spiral
but you can't lock one in a closet and
try to go solve the other problems
and i can't get out of my head the lady
who bought the house for her daughter
who
brought the in the guy shacks up and she
just wants to raise the rent
yeah because as it was a math problem
not well she wanted to punish him yeah
and like that's going to fix it she
wanted to punish him and
not have any relational consequence to
it
right as though
i did all these right things i have my
strong values and so i put the periods
into that sentence
but i'm afraid this is gonna happen yeah
it's gonna happen you put up a boundary
right
yep you took a stand and stands cost you
something
and we uh this is somewhat unrelated but
it's totally related
dave we live in a culture where the way
we show our
yeah is we just thumbs down the crap out
of something
right we click the thumbs up button to
show
that is not taking a stand taking a
stand is saying here are my values
you violated them and i'm willing to
risk your temper tantrum
over what you're going to do because
what this is the right thing
or in this case i've been uh this last
caller
i more than risked the temper tantrum
it's almost anticipated
i'm expecting it that's right i'm going
to anticipate because my values
are my values or i've been so lonely for
20 years
i just need someone to touch someone
look me in the eye at night someone to
tell me that i'm valuable and so i'm
going to
get myself in a mess of a financial
situation i'm going to excel my home
expose myself
to the fact that i may not even be in
this guy's will his kid's going to take
this house i'm going to be 70.
nothing he's he's irresponsible to run
up a bunch of bad debt but i don't even
know how much i don't even know
but i love him and i want this to this
part of this to work
you love the picture the idea that's not
real that's right
that's right so it goes back to what is
that's a great analogy what is this
actual true picture and dave it's hard
for us to do it on ourselves that's why
you gotta have people in your life to do
it with you
it's hard man so what we're
what i what i wanted to cover really in
this segment as we riff through this is
that you cannot separate
the mathematics of personal finance and
move them to the side
and them operate properly when nothing
else in your life is operating properly
you know like 100 of addicts eventually
are broke
100 because the addiction overtakes
every element of their life including
their money
100 they either
start the recovery process or they go
completely broke
there's you cannot stay addicted
over a period of time and become wealthy
it's just impo you cannot make enough
money
and there is there's no accident that
how many times we're gonna do a
debt-free scream and they say by the way
we all lost weight by the way marriage
is so much better i'm a better by the
way
my career got better because i got
honest and i got intentional
and i cleaned up the rough spots of
those areas while i was working on this
money stuff and it all caused the money
thing to win
too right it also the likelihood of you
fixing your money stuff
and not working out the details and the
rough areas of the rest of your life is
almost zero that's what we're saying
which makes it worth going in with both
feet man
yeah you got to go all the way in when
you're going in
this is the ramsey
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america open phones this hour
at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two
five amanda starts off this hour dr john
deloney is my co-host today
and she's in cincinnati hi amanda how
are you
good how are you guys doing better than
i deserve what's up
um we are getting ready to list our
house in about a week or so
we already spoke with a realtor and she
had originally recommended to
listen between 345 to 355 thousand
kind of creating a bidding war um my
husband and i are
somewhat concerned that that's gonna
leave money on the table
that with this market the way that it is
we could list the home higher
and still possibly get a bidding war for
this area
okay well it's just a matter where the
bidding stops not where it starts
okay right okay let's say you
let's say you list it for 355 and the
bidding runs it up to did you you said
three right 355
yes yeah you list it for 355 and the
bidding runs it up to 400.
or you list it for 375 and the bidding
runs it up to 400.
you still got only 400.
my point is where it ends up it's not
where it starts my question is what is
it about your real estate agent
that makes you think you and your
husband are smarter than the
professional you hired
that's a good question that tells me
either you got a crappy professional you
need to get a new one that you trust
or you and your husband need to dial it
back about 30
and let the professional you hire do
their job so what is it about this
person
she is younger so that's always a
concern i've not worked with her before
is she one of our elps she is not
she is a very determined young lady she
has been contacting us
we've been in our house for almost 20
years and she's been contacting us
often throughout those years to check in
to see how things are going to see if
she could offer her services so she's
very proactive and and trying to drum up
business which was
uh how many houses did she sell last
year
i let my husband pick her i didn't do
the research which is not good on my
part
yeah this is this is a four 500 thousand
dollar transaction
and you're hiring a professional you
need to know how often they sell a house
if she sold four houses last year you've
got the wrong person
yeah you don't want a neophyte guiding
you through this market this is not a
market for this not amateur hour
this is a weird market and what you're
worried about is can she handle the
bidding process
and if she's done five or six of these
in the last two months
and can walk you through the
transactional is exactly what happened
uh we'll talk about this and she sold 50
houses last year we'll talk about this
if she sold three houses last year you
know more about it and she does
yeah and amanda i'm giving you a hard
time i just got friends who will go
you know get an x-ray and the doctor
will say hey i think it's this and
that's me they'll go nah that's not
right and i'll think
why did you go to that doctor or they'll
get a roofer out and they'll be like
that's not the problem and the roofer is
like
all right man and so i'm just i just
always curious as why people hire
professionals and then they go
nah that's not right i uh i got google
i'm smarter
so yeah well we have so the problem that
we've run into
is we've hired me many professionals
um or what we thought were professionals
and
um were either able not able to get them
to do the work
most of them we can't get a call back
yeah and then we just end up doing it
ourselves and trying to
already listed the property and signed
the listing agreement
we have not circle back re-interview her
go online at daveramsey.com or
rmzsolutions.com and click on elp
and interview one of those people or two
of those people
and pick among those three based on
their experience
and their ability to show you that they
know how to navigate this
this whacked out white hot market that
we're in and how to navigate the bidding
process
so you know john picking on you is one
thing i've given you a hard time but
yeah but the truth is that you don't
the truth is he did call out that you
just don't have confidence in her
yes yeah and that's what's that's the
end of the story right there so
we need to either gain confidence in her
by circling back one more time and
comparing her to two others
or drop dropper i don't care how
persistent she was
uh you know and so uh because you need
someone to navigate this
and i i think either way you could end
up
at the 400 mark or whatever the mark is
whether you start at
355 or 375
if you've got someone that knows how to
navigate that process and juggle those
multiple offers coming in
set the deadlines set the table properly
where there's a bunch of urgency for
uh you know the 10 people that want to
put in an offer and go guys here's what
we're doing
and uh you know it doesn't matter if you
started at 300
if everybody keeps ratcheting up and
gets you to 400 right
right so again the starting position
doesn't matter who can navigate this
market it's not amateur hour and amanda
this is me being honest here i'm that
that's why i'm the pot talking to the
kettle here
no i do it my wife it drives her crazy
why do we hire people john if you're
just going to disagree with them after
they tell you
what they're playing because i don't
take because i you
you need to be able to defend your
position i love that that's
i i agree with you you know the first
baby we had
we go in and i'm asking all these
questions because i didn't know anything
about it
and uh you know and i'm like no i
what about this i read about this and
he's like back and forth and back and
forth well the nurse that was in there
thought it was ridiculous that i was
asking all these questions like you just
said yeah
and so she called me dr ramsey every
visit after that
how are you doing today dr ramsey and
i'm like well honey
you know maybe you're not used to people
questioning whether you know what the
flip you're doing or not but i'm paying
you you work for me and i'm
happy to ask you if you're competent and
what i've found is true professionals
love teaching about their craft oh she
was she was good natured about it of
course
the whole doctor ramsey sarcasm i had a
roofer out the other night and um
they did some work at my house and i had
a question about some of the work they
did they came out and
they spent once i started asking
questions he loved teaching about
roofing
and he knew exactly what he was talking
about he left his tool with me and said
you use it you bring it back when you're
done with it because i'm i'm right and
i want the bulldozer guy to do that
that would be cool that would be awesome
you use this over the weekend and i'll
be back
i got a moisture meter you got a
bulldozer
but yeah i love i love asking questions
to professionals
and the ones in my experience the ones
who don't have an attitude about it but
are excited to talk about what their
craft is
the doctors like want to send you
research articles want to have a good
discussion with you i love that the
theologians that want to do that but if
they bow up
and they're like the arrogant and
they're like listen i'm the doc
i'm like well listen no you're not
anymore i get another one yeah i'll get
another one
because i'm gonna know enough about
what's going on to
make a decision and at least ask good
questions well i'm i'm steward over my
life
i have to manage my life and you don't
manage my life
you're just a part of what's going on
and you know the mechanic working on my
car
same thing yeah you know it's i'm not
calling you a crook
i just want to understand enough to know
why we're getting where we're getting
and i'm going to critically think with
you once i grasp it through this process
that's right i'm not micromanaging but i
just i
i i'm good with i'm good with this i
want to learn and but
what is it about your real estate agent
that makes you want to question the
professional
[Laughter]
i love it amanda amanda's good this is
awesome this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsay personality is my
co-host
today have you ever made a dumb decision
with zeros on the end because you didn't
do your research
yeah me too check your facts
as we were just talking about if you're
moving a piece of real estate if you're
trying to sell a piece of real estate
particularly right now in this
wacky crazy market it's not amateur hour
you need a pro in your corner
never buy a house without the fax text
house to 33 789
that'll get you in touch with one of our
real estate elps an agent who is a high
protein high
octane agent moving a bunch of
properties and knows how to navigate
this market
especially if you're selling in this
market text
house two three three seven
eight nine thirty three seven eighty
nine megan is with us in greenville
south carolina hi megan how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
i guess i just i guess i just don't know
where to start um my husband and i just
got married in january
congratulations thank you we're renting
i just started a new job
um last september i'm a lawyer and
he just switched jobs working for a big
steel company now he works for my
parents company
and i'm three figures in student debt
combined with his
we have about 10 000 in credit card debt
um probably 30 000 debt and cars
and like i said we rent and we're kind
of at our breaking point
um of like 200 on our checking account
and we just don't know where to
what to even do what is the actual
balance on the student loans
i'd say about 175 okay
and uh what are you making i make 75.
what's he making 50. okay so we have 125
000
to attack this with all right um
well uh the great news is you have a
good degree
uh the bad news is you paid a lot for it
and you're deeply in debt
because of it so you're going to be
shoveling a while
yeah and that's and so and that's hard
because i know that that's
i know that a lot of that is me um i'd
say i've got about 150 and
he's got about 25 so together about 175.
tell me about the cars are they two 15s
or a 20 and a 10 or what
um one's a 2016 f-150 and one's a 2015
acura we're upside down in the f-150 so
what are they worth
um or what do you owe on each what do
you owe on each of them
i owe 25 on the f-150 and we owe
10 on the acura okay you need to sell
the f-150
yes it's ridiculous what if we're upside
down in it
i don't care you need to get rid you're
gonna have to borrow the money to cover
the difference or scrape up the money to
cover the difference
so you owe you owe 25 on it what do you
think it's worth
maybe 20 maybe 19. it's got 175 000
miles
yeah okay yeah that five thousand bucks
gets you out of that thing and
you get a beater car to drive because
you have 175 000
worth of debt to clean up you don't need
a 25 000 pick up
okay it's it's out of control i mean
your 600 truck payment
no it's 645 a month it's crazy like
almost like i've done this before yeah
yeah what
what kind of law are you practicing
civil defense
um so defending defending companies that
have been sued
um and that you know going back to the
student loans i guess
i have the option in the future to go
work for the government and i know no no
no okay you need to just keep working
there and go double your income in the
next four years yeah
yeah that's right and i know that that's
coming because i make 75 now i'm sure
that a raise or a bonus
i think you're you'll be making 100
pretty quick and 100 and a half pretty
quick after that
if you keep on a standard track you know
for for an attorney and you're you know
you have a decent firm and all that kind
of thing
and hopefully your husband's income will
continue to go up as well so
here's what you've signed up for you
need to get into a beater car and get
rid of the pickup
and then you're going to get on a
written game plan a detailed game plan
called a budget
and you're going to live on nothing and
just clean this mess up and it's going
to
take a while two hundred thousand
dollars
if you do 50 000 a year that's going to
be
four years if you do 75 000 a year it's
going to be three years
and that means every big bump you get
every bonus
it means you're not going out to eat
you're not going on vacation and you're
not buying a house you're broke
yeah and listen i speak i spent years
working with lawyers i
love them and they will look at your car
in the parking lot
and then look at you with that disdain
that what did you do all this for if
that's what you're driving
and they're going to ask you while
you're renting they're going to ask you
man you got a mess to clean up
well i'll be honest with you the reason
why i called in today is because that's
literally the question i've been asking
myself um
but for the past month like why did i go
to school this long like why did i take
out all this money
because you're gonna make a hundred and
a half three years from now
yeah and it will be and besides that you
can't un you can't unring the bell it's
there so let's just deal with it yeah
asking backwards
questions gets you nowhere i wouldn't
have signed you up for it but you're
signed up
so now it's about hey what are we gonna
do to
get even and then yeah when you when you
and your husband when
he's making great money you're making
150 and you're
you've made partner if that's even what
you choose to continue to do
you owe nobody any money that stacks up
real real
real fast so i want you to think about
75 000 a year
on debt which means you're gonna take
all the ot he's gonna take all the ot
you're gonna do anything you can to
create income
and you are gonna spend nothing that's
gonna be very hard this year next year
your incomes will go up it'll be easier
and the next year your incomes will go
up again it's going to be even easier
uh but that's that'll get you out in
three years you'll be a hundred percent
debt free in three years if you do that
and you pass the bar exam so i know you
can figure out a way to do this
yes i did um so you think selling the
truck first that's the first order of
business
that's it now we're gonna do it all at
once we're gonna get on a budget live on
nothing and sell the truck
okay but list your debts smallest to
largest payment cut the credit cards up
they've not been a blessing no time to
chop them time for plastic surgery
okay and he's gonna feel like a like a
dingbat driving up to his
construction sites in a in a 2014 camry
and y'all are both y'all are both in it
right you're both in it
you're in it to win it now you don't
care what other people think because
other people are broke
and you're gonna so megan do you think
this will work
yeah i think it'll work so i think we've
just got to do it all right i'm going to
help you do it then i want you to
i want you to go through our class it's
called financial peace university it's
inside of a membership called ramsey
plus
i'm going to pay for it for a year as
your wedding gift oh thank you
and the two of you need to sit down
tonight and start going through the
class
get one of those coaches on your in your
corner gets that community in your
corner
get on every dollar the budgeting app it
all is included it's all free i'm giving
it all to you free
and i want you to work this because you
can do this you can do this but you have
a big mountain to climb
but i've been to the top of it a bunch
of times
like a thousand times this week with
people and so i can show you the way to
the top of that mountain and you're
gonna make it
if you'll do exactly what we tell you to
do i can get you out
but if you screw around start coming up
with your own plan or you water it down
or you start whining you're not gonna
make it but if you roll up your sleeves
and
bow into this plow into it you can do it
hold on
kelly will pick up and we'll get you
signed up to go i love it
man and you get a lawyer focused on
something you better get out of your way
yeah i mean because you don't get
through law school unless you have a
level of determination
perseverance you can grind and grind and
grind for three years it's what you're
asking her to do
yeah and they can do it yeah she just
finished grinding for three years now
three more
that's right and what they're gonna do
is gonna get real resourceful they're
gonna find new jobs they're gonna find
extra jobs and they're gonna
knock that thing out yeah it's going to
go it's going to go she can do it
absolutely she can do it there's no
question about it i'm i'm positive
and you know the the the interesting
thing is you know why
she believes she can yeah that's right
and uh but i mean if you run the numbers
you make a hundred and a quarter now you
live on 75 or you spend 75 on debt that
leaves you 50
000 to live on no you're still having
that's the average household income in
america is 59 000
that's right it's not like we're
actually struggling here
yeah and there's a bunch of taxes coming
out of that and of course you're
evil rich people so the current
president's going to tax your butt off
it sounds like but
um you know that's that's how i'm going
to start it that's a whole other
discussion but yeah
you're gonna get there you're gonna make
it in spite of washington getting in
your way
go go go this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free that's a
if you screw up guarantee who does that
they do you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run all the time you'll save even more i
love this company
blinds.com use the promo code ramsey
all right today's question comes from
amber in georgia
amber writes my husband has three
children from a previous marriage and we
have
four together he's required to pay child
support until his kids are 21
if they live at home and are in college
the oldest is 20
did one semester of college and moved
out on her own
he is still paying child support for all
three of them exclamation point
how do i make him see that that he is
literally ticking away from our
financial peace
by continuing to support the oldest
child
this doesn't sound good dave well she
doesn't live there
anymore why are you sending her mother
money
no no he is i think what she's calling
child support is he's continuing to
support her
probably not routing it through mom
would be my guess
but maybe he is maybe he is still
routing he is still paying child support
for all three of them
yeah i don't know i i it sounds like
she's
i mean i got you know that's that's
silly
yeah if you want to help your 20 year
old that's a different discussion
but if you're not required legally to
pay child support to the ex
anymore because the 20 year old moved
out then i would definitely stop that
right this this is a separate
conversation from child support this is
a conversation dad needs to have the
oldest daughter
and dad needs to have with his current
wife amber and say here's how we are
are not going to support folks yeah i
mean it might be okay there may be a
situation where i would help the 20 year
old
but it would not be a legal child
support obligation to help the 20 year
old right
it sounds like and i've seen this before
that amber's been counting down the days
and the dollars until she can start
seeing some of that money loop back yeah
and the reality is amber these kids are
always going to be his kids
and there's always going to be some sort
of
desire in his heart to see them be
successful what that looks like um is
going to be different which is mean you
all got to work together on this
conversation
you can't again we're back here to
actually can't count down until they're
out of his life because they're not
going to never
have his life but she is again is
circling back to making this a math
problem
how can he see that this money's given
to his child is hurting our financial
situation this is not a
math problem right yeah so you you
signed up
amber with a man who has kids
and so he's not going to quit having
kids they're they're they're there those
kids are always going to be there
doesn't mean he always has to give them
money right but they're always going to
be there
and there's always a potential that he
that that father is going to want to
help his children
that are not your children and that will
always affect your financial peace
and you signed up for that trip kiddo
that's exactly right
the note i just scratched out is you
married him right yeah you got seven
kids between the two of you
but having said that on the technical
aspect of this
i would not be sending child support to
my ex-wife
that i'm not legally required to send
correct i'm going to be having a
grown-up adult conversation with my
grown-up adult child
she's not getting the 20 year old's not
seeing the money anyway x is putting in
her pocket
well if that's happened you can tell
that the 20 year old doesn't live there
anymore
she's falling it off to that 20 year old
she's not yeah
so i yeah in that sense in that sense
i'm with amber
absolutely if he's still sending money
to his ex-wife
that means just with a wink and a nod
that stops immediately yeah that needs
to stop they need to stop the day you're
not obligated now yeah that does
but the fact that he may want to and
actually should help his 20 year old i
don't know what the 20 year old's doing
i don't know what the situation is right
she's out of the house she's out of
college we know that from this call from
this
according to the email anyway but i want
to go back to her uh
her pronouns here how do i make him see
that he he
is hurting our stuff yeah that's bad
that means
hour and you sit down and have an hour
conversation and
um this starts with amber
pulling him aside outside of a a fight
or
argument or a check writing day and this
is over a meal or over a date this is
when y'all go
separate yeah and say what's the plan
here
and that's are you gonna do you no this
is how do i make him see he
is literally taking away from our
financial peace
by continuing to support the oldest one
right wrong
exactly that's just that that has bad
spirit all over it kiddo that's right
that and that's pronoun based bad spirit
and so
you know you signed up for this he he's
not going to he's not going to quit
loving his children right he might quit
and if he
and if you want him to you're going to
have a problem yeah yeah
and if amber pits the four kids they
have together against his three existing
that is that's that's awful it's it's
unethical it's
it's not a um he's the data of all seven
of those kids
he needs to be present and active in the
lives of all seven of those kids to some
degree
right that doesn't mean he's to send him
all money but it's not hey these are our
four kids and those are
y'alls three kids no those are all seven
of his kids
you don't get to slice those over to the
side and hope they go away because
they're not going away
if he's any man of any character they're
not going away right right he'll be
their dad forever
right and it does sound like amber that
you've
uh sounds like amber's been counting
down the days till you're out of your
life
you've put a big machete right between
the two here like
you know crashing down so yeah that's
they're a part of your life
yep you need to embrace that he needs to
you know so the way the conversation
should go
is she sits down with him and says
something like
i think you should be there for your
kids
and i i wouldn't want to be married to a
man that wasn't there for his kids
and uh but sending your ex-wife more
money than you're supposed to legally is
not on that list that's right
and so uh we may need to help the 20
year old
and we're going to always be there
without being enablers
for all seven of these kids to the
extent we can be
but that does not mean we have to send
the ex-wife child support that is not
legally due and now that we've
we've got seven kids and one of them's
hit the age of 20. you're stealing from
my kids to give it to your kids
that's right that's the way this sounds
that's how i read it and hey
here's another a a an even easier way to
ask this question
hey we're gonna have to deal with this
seven times we've got a 20 year old
let's start wrapping our head around how
we're going to support are we going to
pay for tuition do we have that kind of
money are we going to pay for rent we
have that kind of money
let's go ahead and set those have those
conversations now because they're going
to come
seven more times yeah right do that
together
very good amy is in berkeley california
hi amy welcome to the ramsay show
oh hi thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
so i'm a self-employed attorney ah
another attorney
i love it i love it it's the lawyer
through our on the ramsey show
i'm a single mom of two kids um we've
kind of outgrown our house in berkeley
and as you may know the
housing market and uh then northern bay
area
is kind of crazy yeah always has been
intensive to move up
always ask me yeah but so i prepared it
for sale since last november
and uh the goal was to move to a lower
cost area where we have some family in
either houston or
florida um i've gotten a little stuck
and i've not been able to actually lift
it for sale
but i need to make a decision about that
or else selling um two investment
properties that i have
well i have about 45. what are you stuck
on
um you know i think i'm tied to the
house in some respects
um i in 2009 with the recession
then i went through
an almost foreclosure uh i fought
against my lender
in order to keep the house and um was
able
to um you know you're not gonna make a
bunch of money on it when you sell it
yes i will are you stuck psychologically
emotionally
psychologically yeah um
i think it has something to do with the
move i think yeah it's psychologically
or emotional
i think you need to decide whether you
want to have this adventure or not and
when if you're gonna have the adventure
everything needs to be sold and you need
to go have the adventure yeah move to
texas move to florida
start over you're obviously a really
smart really tough
big old pile of money in your pocket
brilliant woman yeah
go for it i'm for the adventure i am too
i like the adventure
but i don't know breadcrumbs back to the
cave though sell everything
yeah and if you've got a psychological
attachment to this house it's got to go
you and your family come first
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day isaiah 66 9 i
will not cause
pain without allowing something new to
be born
says the lord
john wooden says things work out best
for those who make the best of how
things work out travis is with us in
buffalo
hi travis welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi dr john how are you guys
doing
great how can we help okay so
well me and my girlfriend have been
going out for two and a half years and
we're living together and
well when it comes to money we're kind
of
she kind of does her thing and i kind of
do my thing
on like i follow you guys on your steps
and everything
and like my question is
like how do i
like not get her like to tell her to
come on jump on board
but like to understand like
what i'm doing what are you doing
um i'm pretty much i'm on baby step
number two
i'm no i wasn't i was i was being a
little bit facetious
like
what's your what's your future with this
with this woman
um like i planned on marrying her in the
next
probably cup a year
or so does she plan on being married to
you back
um we have talked about it i mean
that is definitely one of our futures
goals
like we also talked about kids and all
that
so like we do plan on having a future
together and all that and
and it's like to keep with my steps
and everything else like that i want her
to understand
like how i deal with that
so does she not like it or she doesn't
agree with it
um like she kind of does her
own way of things like
like if she needs something she'll go
get it herself
and like i've kind of been
like on the front of i don't know
exactly if we should start working
together
or as like a team
before marriage like
combining income and all that or
anything like that how old are you
i'm 25. how old is she she's 25 as well
okay all right the problem you're having
is
it's hard to be sort of married
yeah it's like being sort of pregnant
and and you're trying to act like you're
married in some ways and not act like
you're married in other ways and it's
not working because it doesn't work
and so we see this all the time in
couples that are shacked up they have a
very very difficult time
because it's it's it's legally and
relationally
uh unwise for you to combine everything
but and yet you're trying to act like
you're married which would indicate that
you would combine everything
and so i don't really know how to advise
you well
on this yeah um you know unless you
just decided okay we're going to live in
two separate places
and date and we're going to
start talking about the value systems
that we have
about saving money about spending money
about debt
about our future and what it would look
like if we were to combine our
households and if we were to get married
how are we going to make them one and on
the same page
and you can try that while you're living
together but it's going to be very
difficult
as you've already discovered and so um
you know i think you can you know that's
probably the first step actually is you
say
look we cannot operate our lives
for 40 years 50 years going forward the
way they're operating now
on two separate pages on two separate
planes this is not a recipe for success
we if we're going to have a future
together we're going to have to start
figuring out how we're going to put our
life together and what it's going to
look like
and the wedding ceremony is not the the
joining it up it's the life
that you build intertwined with one
another yeah does that make sense
yeah in other words you don't have to
convince her of anything except that
that not being on the same page is a
deal breaker
because dude it's a deal breaker it's
the number one cause of divorce
yeah like for me it was just
i felt like
like i'm not meaning i wasn't like joint
income it was like because
i was in like for me it was i was
spending
so much because we did the separation
for a while
and made that try to make it work but
then i was like for me
i was financially spending too much on
travel
and food expenses and stuff like that
yeah you're you're missing what we're
saying you're
you're trying to make this a math
problem brother and this is not a math
problem
this is a unity problem yeah this is the
two of you don't see the future the same
correct and therefore the future is not
going to be together
until you can see the future the same
and so
when you have a conversation that sounds
like um
if we're going to move forward in this
relationship and move towards marriage
then we're going to have to start
talking about the four
things that affect marriages money
religion in-laws and kids and if you can
be in agreement on those four things
in your pre-marriage state
pre-marriage counseling engagement
period
those kinds of things you can come into
agreement how
you don't have to have kids but you just
gotta say i don't want six kids well i
want ten
well we got a problem uh i think kids
ought to be able to make up
all their own decisions from the time
they're three on i don't i think they
ought to do what i say
well that's going to be a problem i
think my mother ought to be able to come
over here and tell us what to do
well i think that's a problem in-laws
kids
problems money i think ought to be able
to spend whatever i want to spend no
matter what as long as i make money
it'll be my money and you make money and
you take care of the rest of the house
well i don't think that's how we're
going to do it
problem so you need to be in agreement
on
religion i don't think there's a god i'm
sure there's a god and i think people
that don't think there's a god's an
idiot well then that's a problem
and so you know you need to be in
agreement on marriage
money in-laws and kids and your
pre-marriage state
otherwise you don't have a candidate for
marriage
you've had a fun roommate and a maybe a
good
compadre for the last two years but you
don't have someone to build
an entire future with together i think i
think you've got to go
sit down and say where we want this
thing if it worked out perfectly
what would we want this to look like and
reverse engineer it
right now it sounds like brother you are
just stumbling and tripping
and i think i'll do this and i think
we're going to do this but i'd like to
do that
even your verbal pattern is very
uncertain travis yeah
it's like you you have no certainty
about where you're headed
and so you need to sit down and go we're
gonna if we're gonna move forward in
this
or you could just languish in this you
can choose that but you're asking us how
to get
you know get on the same page and it's
lay out what the page looks like
on all of these things and go you know
we need to start talking through these
things
if we're going to move forward it's not
just can we share the mustard
that's going to be on my t-shirt yeah
marriage can we share them
can we share the mustard because you
know if you got two things of mustard
that's what you have with a roommate
you got two mustards that's my mustard
your mustard yes and right there in the
door of the refrigerator and don't touch
my mouth
i got it remember yeah dave's mustard
don't mess with dave's mustard
hey so i i know you should probably be
asking me me this question but
you've done this for way longer than me
so i
i came into marriage almost two decades
ago
with a very clear list of the things i
wanted values i thought were were deal
breakers for me things that were i was
really firm on
here's what i think about kids and
probably the most recurring theme over
the last two decades is
i was wrong right i thought i wanted
this many kids and i thought
as long as you're in agreement that's
okay all along i don't care
that we're gonna solve you could get
married saying i want ten kids and five
years later the two of you have traveled
the world you go
i think the two of us are looking at
each other going we want a chihuahua or
you have kid one and you're like
i'm out i'm out tap out that one right
there that did it
that second one that did it for sure
sure yeah we're gonna make these
decisions together
yeah not hours and yeah yours and mine
it's yeah and not not
you know but you can't come in and go
you know you get married going i want 10
kids and then you go i changed my mind
unilaterally without discussing with the
other friends that's not a showdown
that's right that puts us our of
the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
you